die nasa hat jetzt verkündet dass schon
2024 die erste frau überhaupt den mond
betreten soll dann will die
raumfahrtagentur nämlich ein team zum
südpol des mondes schicken um dort nach
wasser zu suchen klicks um science
fiction die gibt es täglich
faszinierende songs videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nicht los
geht's herzlich willkommen staubtrocken
und sandig eine echte krater büßte
ebenso stellte man sich lange zeit den
mond vor
doch in den vergangenen jahren haben
forschungsteams weltweit viele spannende
erkenntnisse gewinnen können
zum beispiel geht die nasa von 100 bis
200 millionen tonnen wasser aus die
unterirdisch auf dem mond lagern zudem
wurden große wassereis ablagerungen in
den kratern an den mondpolen entdeckt
doch warum ist der mond boden doch gar
nicht so knochentrocken wie bislang
gedacht und woher kommen diese
wasserspuren das ist ein wirklich
langjähriges rätsel dem einen nasa
forschungsteam jetzt auf die schliche
gekommen ist dazu hatten die fachleute
daten analysiert die die sonde luna
atmosphäre entlässt environment explorer
die bei ihrer umkreisung des mondes
zwischen oktober 2013 und april 2014
gesammelt hatte die untersuchung dieser
daten offenbart eine wirklich
außergewöhnlich hohe wasser
konzentration in der atmosphäre des
mondes aber nicht immer 29 fälle mit
dieser abweichung konnte die nasa konnte
das nasa forschungsteam aus machen und
zwar jedes mal nachdem der verband auf
meteoriten ströme getroffen war die
schlussfolgerung solche kleinen
meteoriteneinschläge setzen
offensichtlich also wasser aus den
tieferen bodenschichten des mondes frei
vor allem gesteinsbrocken mit einer
bestimmten masse und geschwindigkeit
sorgten für eine freisetzung des wassers
in dem mond atmosphäre der aktuellen
analyse zufolge handelt es sich dabei um
brocken die mit einer geschwindigkeit
von mehr als 30 kilometern in der
sekunde eingeschlagen waren
zudem sind lediglich meteoriten die
mindestens eine masse von 0 15 gramm
aufweisen dazu in der lage tiefere
schichten freizulegen leichter
gesteinsbrocken verursachen keine
freisetzung von wasser so dass die
fachleute schlussfolgern dass die oberen
cm des mondboden völlig trocken sind in
einer tiefe von mehr als 8 cm beträgt
der wassergehalt des bodens der
aktuellen studie zufolge bis zu 0,05
prozent und der wasserverluste nhs mond
bodens durch meteoriteneinschläge ist
nicht ohne pro jahr sind es bis zu 200
tonnen dieses ergebnis wiederum lässt
rückschlüsse zu wie der mond überhaupt
zu dem wasser gekommen ist diese
verlustrate spricht dem nasa
forschungsteam zufolge dafür dass das
wasser von beginn an relativ gleichmäßig
im mondboden vorhanden gewesen sein muss
oder aber sehr früh auf den noch jungen
mond gelangt sein muss fest steht also
die la die sonde hat es erstmalig
ermöglicht diesen prozess der wasser
freisetzung ausführlich zu beobachten
und zu verstehen und klar ist auch dass
das wasser auf dem mond für zukünftige
missionen eine entscheidende rolle
spielen könnte gerade am 12 mai hatte
die nasa mitgeteilt schon 2024 ein team
zum südpol des mondes zu schicken dazu
der nasa wissenschaftler james key
geplant ist dass 2024 eine bemannte
missionen auf den mond stattfinden soll
diesmal soll aber kein mann sondern eine
astronautin zuerst aussteigen
insgesamt soll das team aus vier oder
fünf astronauten bestehen zwei unser
breit auf dem mond einer oder zwei neben
der umlaufbahn
das ziel ist die suche nach wasser das
auch für künftige mars-mission wichtig
sei james king geht davon aus dass ende
der 30er jahre erstmals menschen auf dem
mars landen können das aufspüren von
wasser auf dem mond sei dafür ein
weiterer meilenstein denn zum einen sei
es natürlich als trinkwasser nutzbar
aber eben auch um aus den bestandteilen
sauerstoff und wasserstoff zum einen
atemluft und zum anderen treibstoff für
eben eine mars-mission herzustellen
und dann kann vielleicht auch diese
frage geklärt werden kommt das leben vom
mars draufklicken anschauen und astro
comics tv abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran